and i welcome our last speaker
and it's certainly
possibly one of the most interesting
ones so please do bear with us and stay
colin touch a science writer and
broadcaster with an expertise in what he
calls eco eating and real farming
colin um
your
game changer in a way is the most
intuitive in some ways the most
straightforward because it's about
changing behavior it doesn't require
sort of crazy technology but in some
ways the hardest because in some ways it
goes to the heart perhaps of the very
philosophy we live by and so my question
really is to kick you off is this
compatible
um
with our economic dogma today and with
the idea of economic growth as we know
it it's not compatible with the economic
dogma of today i think it's perfectly
compatible with as it were human
psychology
the dogma of the day is very much out of
sync with what human beings are really
like and what we really want so in that
sense it ought to be easy and it ought
to be
um
technically easy too and the the
generalizations are we can't really
disagree with that however efficiently
we produce energy and however
ingeniously we dispose of surplus carbon
and all the rest
the ideal must be to use as little
energy as possible
while maintaining the sort of convivial
and peaceful and just kind of existence
that we want
and the second thing that seems to me to
be intuitively obvious we'd all agree
with is that the thing we absolutely
have to get right
is food production in other words
agriculture and in fact agriculture
impinges on absolutely everything that
we do
and if we get agriculture right then
everything else that we aspire to
including world peace and justice and so
on that all becomes possible but if you
get the agriculture wrong then
everything else you want to do is
compromise so it's the thing you
absolutely have to get right
and getting it right i think and this is
a moral point as much as anything
getting it right means that you have to
feed everybody that there is on the
earth and everybody that is ever going
to be on the earth so now we have to
feed seven billion people and by 2050
we're going to have to feed nine and a
half billion people
the good news is that the united nations
demographers tell us that the rate of
increase is actually going down i mean
percentage rate of increase is going
down and that by 2050 the percentage
rate of increase will be zero on present
projections which means that the
population should more or less stabilize
at nine and a half billion shouldn't get
any bigger than that and in fact we'll
start to go down within a few decades
possibly or certainly within a few
centuries so now for the first time in
tens in 10 000 years since agriculture
was first practiced on a proper on a big
scale we can see that the problem of
feeding the human race is actually
finite it's not going to go shooting up
like this like this as malta's said
forever until it crashes it's actually
going to do that and we can see what the
size of the task is so the question is
can we feed 7 billion people now and
nine and a half by 2050
and according to the government and the
government reports that they produce
this is going to be very difficult and
you know one of the latest government
reports says we're going to have to
produce 50 more food by 2050 in order to
you know in order to pull through and
all that kind of stuff and for
to do that we're going to need biotech
and gm and all that kind of stuff
and i say this is actually complete
nonsense it should be perfectly easy to
feed 7 billion people and in fact hans
heron of something called the iaa std
and i can never remember what it stands
for but the t stands for technology
um
and he is one of the serious authorities
in the world and he points out that in
principle we already actually produce
enough food
calories in protein to feed 14 billion
people so there shouldn't be a problem
and we're already in fact producing more
than we will need ever to you know to
feed the population and it is at its
biggest
in other words there really shouldn't be
a problem and i wrote a book a little
while ago called feeding people is easy
and i've now updated it and i'll plug it
because there are a few rounds and this
one is called good food for everyone
forever and it simply says that it is
actually quite easy to produce good food
for everyone forever and we shouldn't be
making a fuss about it and we should be
able to do is much much less
fuel and energy than we are now using
and this is this is why it's relevant
particularly relevant to tonight's
discussion now the question then is how
do you produce enough food for seven
billion and for nine and a half billion
and the answer is blindingly simple the
answer is that you design agriculture as
if this is what you were trying to do
and
create agriculture that is specifically
expressly designed to provide everybody
with good food without wrecking the rest
of the world that's the requirement and
it's actually quite easy and i call that
kind of agriculture enlightened
agriculture and because enlightened
agriculture has got too many syllables
we started calling it real farming and
we now have something called the
campaign for real farming now how
what what does you know what are the
principles here well the first thing is
that agriculture that feeds everybody of
course has to be productive but we've
already covered that we we know it can
be productive enough that's not a
problem the second thing it has to be
sustainable and sustainable doesn't mean
that you have to be able to go on doing
exactly the same thing forever it means
though that you have to be able to farm
forever in other words you might
choose to change crops at some point but
you have to maintain the fertility which
of course farmers traditional farmers
have been saying for the last 10 000
years that's the job
and the third thing you have to do and
we've heard about
in this age of climate change in
particular is to be resilient you have
to have agriculture that can change
direction
when the conditions change and the
question is then how do you do that and
the answer very simply is that you
emulate nature which has been productive
and
sustainable and resilient for the last
three and a half billion years more or
less without interruption despite the
mass extinctions they did recover after
all and how does nature do
here and there the um
how does nature do it the answer is
first of all that it is very very
diverse don't need to expand on that it
is very tightly integrated
and it is minimum input
little as possible goes most ecosystems
use what's there they also borrow from
all over the place but they mostly use
what's actually there
how does that translate into agriculture
diversity means polyculture lots of
different crops grown side by side
genetically diverse crops genetically
diverse and livestock
secondly integration means integration
everything should be feeding on
everything else
and low input actually means organic and
that doesn't really mean that you have
to follow all the rules of the soil
association but it does mean that
organic has to be your default position
and if anybody says can organic farming
really feed the world the answer is yes
it can the calculations have been done
the demonstrations are out there it's
not actually that difficult
if you have farms which are
diverse and integrated and quasi-organic
they are bound to be very very complex
if they're very very complex they're
going to be labor intensive not just
labor not coolies but skills intensive
and therefore there's no advantage in
scale up and therefore actually your
your your default farm your average farm
if there is such a thing should be small
to medium-sized
and that's what the future lies with
small to medium-sized mixed integrated
quasi-organic skills intensive farms in
other words with the kind of farms that
in structure not necessarily in
technology but in structure are what one
would call traditional and are the kind
of farms that we had in britain for
example until about the 1960s
and i'm not talking about a simple
reversion to the past i mean we have to
have appropriate technologies that goes
with it and all those kind of things
first of all this kind of these kind of
farms demonstrably can feed everybody as
it were quite easily but secondly they
also provide us with the best possible
food because if you do the detailed
structure of what you actually put into
the farms you find you need a great many
plants because you should focus on
arable and horticulture you have some
livestock which you integrate into the
farm in various ways and you stick your
sheep up on the hill and all that kind
of stuff so you certainly have some
livestock and you have huge variety so
you finish up producing a lot of plants
not much meat and maximum variety and
a lot of plants not much meat and
maximum variety summarizes in nine words
all the nutritional theory of the last
40 years i mean that's it it's libraries
but you can summarize it in those
nine words
and it also summarizes the basis
of all the world's great cuisines
they're all done like this they're all
very rich in plants or great cuisines i
mean meat is used as a garnish or as a
stock or an occasional feast but never
used to excess and hugely various and
the turks are wonderful the way they
make wonderful feasts out of walnuts and
wheat and mint and a few other things
and if a goat dies that bit in there and
so on so on that's what great cooking is
actually about
to do this in britain we need about a
million new farmers because we have
we've got one percent of people on the
land five hundred thousand people we
need at least three thousand three times
that many and i think we need probably
five times that many and that is roughly
equivalent of course to the number of
unemployed young people and about a
third so it actually would work rather
well
to me it is actually abundantly obvious
that this is what we need to do we need
to go down this what we are calling the
an agrarian route we need to rebalance
the economy
and the question is why don't we do it
and the answer is
because british agriculture or world
agriculture now like everything else is
plugged into the dogma of neoliberalism
and neoliberalism says we're all in a
global market we all have to compete and
we all have to produce as much money as
possible in the shortest possible time
this is the priority produce a lot of
money in the goodest possible time not
to produce good food if you want to
produce a lot of money in the shortest
possible time you must maximize
production that's that's rule number one
parliament high
and one can say that the kind of
agriculture i'm talking about in
traditional agriculture you're content
to produce enough you're content to
produce what people actually need
with if you've got the philosophy of
trying to make as much money as possible
there's no such thing as enough you want
to renew we want to remove the ceilings
of production if you've got too much
food you turn it into biofuel you remove
the ceiling
agriculture expands to fill the space
available
two minutes if you have um
the second thing you have to do if you
want to make money is to is to add value
take something cheap and turn it into
something dear so you take strawberries
from israel and you flog them christmas
in sainsbury's and so on and so on and
so all that kind of stuff and you turn
cheap wheat and cheap maize which you
can make perfectly good food out of
you feed it to livestock or do you knock
down the amazon and you grow soyo and
you feed that to pigs and that's among
other things it is is adding value the
third thing you have to do is to cut
costs and that is the most dangerous of
all first of all all the epidemics that
livestock has suffered in this country
over the last 30 years bsc foot and
mouth spine flu spine fever bird flu i'm
sure there's a few others i must have
missed but one after the other and
sometimes several together all caused by
cut price husbandry all of them all
caused by cutting costs primarily
secondly if you're going to go down the
route of um
cutting costs you have above all to get
rid of labor if you get rid of labor you
cannot think about complexity you cannot
think about variety you have to do the
thing on the biggest possible scale with
the biggest possible machines you have
to let chemistry take care of the weeds
and the fertility and all that kind of
stuff in other words the farming becomes
an exercise in industrial chemistry
industrial chemistry alfresco one minute
thank you and um
all this biotech is basically um
bells and whistles
the um
there's an irony in here and if you say
this kind of thing to as it were the
powers that be government and so on they
will say you're a greenie which is of
course a shocking thing to do
you know or you're or you're you're red
you know your commie because you're with
all that kind of stuff
and they say you're just an ideologue
you know get out of here actually no
what i'm talking about is pure realism
what you actually need to do in
biological terms in order to provide
enough food that is sheer realism it's
the ideologues are are those who are
plugged into the the neoliberal economy
as it were come what may now i reckon my
last point
government is not going to do anything
about this because the neoliberal
economy rules in their economic growth
all that kind of stuff that's all you
ever hear about
so
various friends of and myself and lots
of farmers and my wife actually we set
up something a few years ago called the
campaign for real farming which had a
website called www campaign for
realfarming.org
and the idea is that we try and bring
about a people's takeover of the world's
food supply nothing less will do
and the point is not to have a fight not
to have a revolution and not either to
try sort of by weak reform to sort of
persuade the government to change their
ways or tesco to change their ways
because they're not going to do it but
the point is to affect what we are
calling an agrarian renaissance for
people just to start doing things
differently and to this end this is why
i'm a i'm a good capitalist really
we're advocating uh ethical investment
and there's a new company setting up to
do this and that's all i've got to say
thank you very much
well
that was a lot of good food for thought
um
and in the spirit you know who can argue
with good food for everyone forever
any questions
the lady in the pink shirt let's cluster
maybe with the with the gentleman behind
so the microphone can efficiently stay
over there for a second
hi there my name's sarah gordon i'm
daughter of a struggling scottish farmer
um and given that we're talking about
energy here and and great if we go down
the route that you've just described
obviously we're reducing the amount of
energy that needs to be going into the
farming however people don't live where
you've got prime fertile land etc and i
can talk from experience coming from
scotland
so what do we do about distribution do
we need to put more energy into our
distribution or we just do we just
persuade the world's population to move
to those areas where you can actually
grow food
can we just have the second question
um this is two connected questions which
is uh how much will this cost and how
will you persuade a million people to
that they want to be farmers
right
the first point is that
funnily enough if you analyze the total
transport costs of agriculture transport
is isn't actually a huge part of it i
believe there's something like five
percent of the whole despite bringing uh
cut flowers from kenya to sell in in the
high street so i'm bringing food
therefore from from say the hills of
scotland sheep down to oxfordshire is is
not such a big deal in fact well didn't
worry too much about that i would that
would think much more in terms of
national self-reliance than we present
currently do in other words it's
actually you can demonstrate quite
easily that virtually every country in
the world with the exception of people
like singapore and so on could be
self-reliant in food in other words they
could produce enough for their own
populations
and in a country like ours we would be
importing bananas and coffee and tea and
stuff like that provided we pay for it
properly you know fair trade and all
that stuff
um but
if you then will have you base your
cuisine on
on what you grow locally which
traditionally we did and it was very
very good and even the scots used to
have a very good cuisine in the olden
days um
you can live pretty well without you
know it's not it shouldn't be a problem
that's not the problem it's the amount
of fertility that goes in it's the
amount of cultivations that go in
and the packaging and all that all that
kind of stuff that really does it what
was the other question that cost how
much does it cost
oh the million people persuading bit you
don't need to i mean i give loads of
talks not necessarily audiences like
this but loads and there simply is no
doubt that lots
lots and lots and lots of people i
haven't nobody's done a survey to find
out how many would really like to go
back to the land if we're talking about
a million new farmers we're talking
about a 30th of the um
of the british workforce that's not very
that's not very much
and
there are just loads of people out there
who would really love to get back it's
not a question of persuading it's a
question of making it possible what you
need is something like a career ladder
we don't have that at the moment so
there are various things like community
supported agriculture and various local
groups whereby the community employs
people to become farmers and that kind
of thing various ad hoc um arrangements
but between them they can they can add
up to something
cost transitional costs are always uh
look expensive i mean one reason why
supermarket food can look cheap although
that isn't actually
if you analyze it it's not really cheap
at all but it looks it because it's very
deceptively priced but the main reason
it looks cheap is because the whole
economy is now geared to that kind of
arrangement and it isn't geared to local
production and local uh sales and so on
and so on again the carbon price right
that isn't in there in a way yeah yeah
if what if if the economy you know
it's a question of momentum if the
economy were geared to the small farm in
the local economy then you'd find it
would actually be cheaper than what
we've now got because you're saving so
much in in costs right we've got a last
question this is a lot of pressure on
you
right here
can i have that no the in fact it's i'm
sorry
maybe you can talk to mr
sorry
hello uh rob bailey from chatham house
um i'm slightly less confident than you
are that the evidence shows that organic
farming can feed nine billion people
certainly from what i've seen there are
some remarkable case studies showing
very significant yield and productivity
increases but these are often very hard
to replicate and you can make similar
level similar arguments against gm
some field trials for gm show very
remarkable increases in productivity but
it can be very difficult to replicate
and the point here is that agriculture
technologies are highly context specific
what works in one place doesn't
necessarily work
in another it depends on land tenure
market institutions access to finance
access to knowledge
the the particular position that the
farmers in so how confident are you
really that this top-down almost
one-size-fits-all approach that you're
advocating
can meet these challenges and i'm
thinking particularly now about some of
the most food insecure countries in the
world where population growth is very
rapid and so depletion is extremely
desperate
i think my solution is is far less top
down and far less one size fits all than
the one we have at the moment which is
very much controlled from the top and is
very much the big industrial model
my point about organic farming
i am pretty convinced that if it's done
well and it's very hard to do it well
that in most contexts it would work i
mean there are lots and lots of examples
of it working well there are lots of
figures that show you know et cetera et
cetera also works can work very very
well over time
which which you know you take a 10-year
average with your mixed crops this is
all part of it
and
you you find that even though in the
peak years it's not as good as the
industrial way of doing it over the time
it is because you know you lose on some
when you gain on others that kind of
thing the other thing is i would i had i
said you know that
one
initially one should regard
um organic as the default position it's
the thing you aim for
but you don't if if you find for
whatever reason it's not working i mean
i would say well you know bung in some
nitrogen if you really feel you've got
to do it
but um
so you can overcome all that kind of
problem
um what was the other point you made
oh my oh
oh
well sub-saharan africa i mean we are in
good contact with
quite a lot of african farmers i wish we
were in contact with more but it's a
question of having you know enough
people to keep in touch there's there
simply is no doubt i mean the
alternative for them is to is to get
stuff from
the you know rich countries and all that
kind of stuff there's no doubt that most
african countries could easily be
self-reliant in food which would be a
much better position than trying to make
lots of money and then importing basic
stuff that they could be growing and
there's no doubt
from anybody that i've ever talked to
who knows about orga
african farming that the route to go
down is organic certainly adapted to the
conditions of course always
but that has to be the route
right i think we're going to have to
leave it there but i promised you a vote
so very quickly i know these five game
chainers aren't necessarily competing
with one another um and in the future
perhaps we'll see an energy mix
including all of these technologies but
you as voters and tax payers can have a
very informal show of hands for each of
the five game changers that you would be
most likely to want your tax pounds to
be spent on let's start with
uh initiative number one which was ccs i
believe
show of hands
ccs
okay
right generation iv nuclear energy
can i have an alternative vote to that
how many of the ones who didn't vote for
this would have voted for it before
fukushima
anyone
okay
um
solar energy
right
driverless rail caps
a few people
and eco eating and real farming
what it looks to me that sola won the
floor tonight
it certainly is
the biggest source of energy
well that was a fascinating debate i am
very varied and i don't claim to be able
to summarize it i might try anyways
because i'm a journalist and you know
what we do we simplify first and then we
exaggerate
so um perhaps in one sentence the one
thing i feel i learned tonight is that
the frontier or the limitation is no
longer technology which which is what it
used to be with politicians pushing
ahead today i believe it's the other way
around it seems to me from what we heard
technology is actually becoming more
viable and what we need is politicians
to actually drive up the political will
and ultimately really go for the final
and ultimate game changer in energy and
that is a carbon price
thank you very much